l'élection de joe biden et ses
conséquences sur le commerce mondial
après le protectionnisme tout crin des
années trump et la sortie des états unis
de nombreux accords commerciaux
l'arrivée du démocrate à la maison
blanche peut-elle calmer le jeu bay
d'annoncé est un tenant du
multilatéralisme mais va-t-il pour
autant inverser la tendance et renouer
avec à la chine et l'europe
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bienvenus
chaque jour stéphanie bonsoir jacques
alors l'élection américaine peut-elle
apporter un changement majeur dans la
politique commerciale des etats unis
beaucoup se posent la question en tout
cas oui effectivement c'est fini on sait
que donne un train pavés et
spectaculairement rompu certains accords
commerciaux etc il s'affirmait
ouvertement protectionnistes alors son
successeur probable je dis bien probable
car les résultats de l'élection de
seront néanmoins définitif que le 14
décembre comme un 10-1 précédent invités
et bien son successeur probable amènera
avec lui certainement un changement de
style peut penser que la politique du
tweet ravageur est sans doute terminée
mais si on regarde la politique
commerciale des etats-unis on peut
douter en fait que sur le fond il y ait
une si grande différence
alors jacques droite en s'attendre à ce
que les états unis reviennent au libre
échange
non non c'est qu'annie et pour une très
bonne raison
les etats-unis ont toujours été un pays
très protectionniste et ceci en dépit
d'un discours à par an en faveur du
libre-échange
vous savez ce que me disait d'ailleurs
mais mes professeurs il ya fort
longtemps dans la politique américaine
le libre échange c'est un produit
d'exportation pas un produit de
consommation intérieure jacques la
politique de donald trump avait quand
même pourtant bien signifier un tournant
protectionnistes oui mais en fait c'est
fini ce que l'on a retenu de sa
politique c'est essentiellement la
sortie de ces grands accords commerciaux
de fait et si vous voulez on peut le
voir justement sur ce graphique qui est
réel
c'est par l'organisation mondiale du
commerce en fait les états unis n'ont
pas cessé depuis des années de prendre
des mesures protectionnistes
on voit par exemple que dans les deux
dernières années du mandat de barack
obama
il ya eu un très grand nombre de ces
mesures protectionnistes
ainsi de 2009 à 2016
il ya aussi de nombreuses mesures qui
ont été prises pour des motifs dits
phytosanitaires mais qui ont ou réalité
servi à bloquer un certain nombre
d'importations agricole alors pour vos
jacques dans un endroit où se situerait
dans la continuité de la politique
commerciale américaine
oui oui effectivement bien sûr les
méthodes qui l'employait
ça décoiffe et un peu ça c'est très
clair mais sur le fond sa politique elle
était beaucoup plus dans la continuité
que dans la rupture
vous savez on comptait au mois de juin
2020 pas moins de 526 mesure faisant
obstacle au commerce international en
vigueur aux états unis c'est un nombre
considérable et sur ses 526 mesure il
faut savoir que les trois quarts étaient
antérieurs à donald trump et pourtant ce
dernier avait spécifiquement suivez la
chine faut-il s'attendre au squat joe
biden change de politique
non non non là encore non c'est fini
parce que cette politique d'affrontement
économique et technologique il faut le
rappeler avec la chine fait l'objet d'un
profond accord entre les démocrates et
les républicains aux états unis cette
politique
en réalité c'est ce qu'on appelle
typiquement une politique bipartisane
alors il n'y a pas de raison qu'elle
change bien sûr un job hayden y mettra
des formes que donald trump n'y aurait
pas misé mais l'orientation générale de
cette politique restera inchangée il le
fait que le sénat des états unis qui va
rester on le sait maintenant aux mains
des républicains sera toujours justement
un sénat républicain devrait beaucoup
faire pour la continuité de cette
politique
et en ce qui concerne nous intéresse
particulièrement l'union européenne
alors oui effectivement un job à raiden
affirment soutenir et aimer l'europe
seulement il nous faudra apprendre à
distinguer les mots et les actes
en effet là encore il ya un profond
d'accord au sein de l'élite américaine
cette dernière considère ainsi que
l'allemagne est un ennemi commercial
pratiquement au même titre que la chine
de même les états unis s'opposeront
aussi à la france sur le dossier boeing
airbus
elle ne reculera devant rien pour
sauvegarder la position prééminente de
boeing ou de là rien ne montre que les
etats unis soient prêts justement à
renoncer à leur mesure dite extra
territorial qui pénalise lourdement en
priorité des entreprises européennes
alors quelles sont les mesures
auxquelles vous faites référence
ces mesures paradoxalement elles ont été
prises sous la présidence de barack
obama qui était pourtant considéré comme
un président très favorable au
multilatéralisme et à la mondialisation
il s'agit de deux choses tout d'abord
rial le foreign corrupt practices act
qui pue d'idées des actes de corruption
et pierre lefort qui s'assure que vous
êtes bien en accord avec la loi fiscale
américaine
mais ces mesures autorisant réalité les
états les états unis à pénaliser des
sociétés étrangères si elles
n'appliquent pas des décisions
américaines alors qu'elle ne travaille
pas sur le sol américain
par exemple le foreign account tax
compliance act a été considérablement
aggravée par une décision des autorités
américaines
celle de considérer que ton usage du
dollar entre deux sociétés
même si ces deux sociétés ne sont pas
sur le sol des états unis même si elles
ne dépendent pas des états dits et bien
que cette puce 1 du dollar faisait
automatiquement tomber ces deux sociétés
sous le coup de la loi américaine
alors des sociétés françaises par
exemple alstom technique et puis des
banques aussi comme bnp paribas le
crédit agricole ou la société générale
ont été condamnés et ont été condamnés
demain du fait de ces procédures donc en
clair va vous n'attendez pas grand chose
finalement de travail d'anne non
absolument vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est fini le nouveau président continue
aura la politique de son prédécesseur
ce dernier avait en réalité continuer
voire jédir et aggraver la politique de
son propre prédécesseur la priorité
donnée par les états unis à
l'affirmation unilatérale de leurs
intérêts se maintiendra peut-être que
joe barton y mettra des formes mais
peut-être pas de même la priorité donnée
aux relations avec la chine
une priorité qui date en fait de barack
obama va se maintenir
enfin les états unis continueront de
vouloir que les pays européens ne soient
que des consommateurs ward et sous
traitants mais certainement pas des
acteurs importants du commerce
international des producteurs importants
de biens cruciaux comme je vous le
disais en introduction pour les états
unis
le libre échange c'est un produit
d'exportation et certainement pas un
produit de consommation intérieure mais
merci jacques nous avoir fait réfléchir
la continuité sans changement donc merci
à vous